hi guys I'm just module it is the third
of January and you're tuned into our
gamespot news top 5 show where I run you
down on five of the most interesting
things that happened over the last week
since we have been on hiatus let's go
over the holiday period
the issue of gender in gaming has been
brought up again this time by a naughty
dog Deb who reckons the portrayal of
women and games needs to be changed user
interface designer Alexandria neone
asker's have said that the members women
cycle needs to stop as does the tendency
to make women damsels in distress or men
shoehorned into women's bodies in
defense of the last of us she made
mention of the last of us is Ellie as a
triumph in female character portrayal do
you guys think this issue is problematic
or is it improving leave me your word
pictures next up another weird problem
is surface with the Xbox one since it
things that some of them are leaking as
for the what apparently some sort of oil
is escaping a couple of the fancy black
boxes as reported by several users one
such individual posted to the official
xbox support forum saying that the
leakage only occurs after playing for
multiple hours another instance saw a
gamer recording that an Xbox one was
leaking a milky white residue which
eventually dried up and the problem
resolved itself you microsoft said
they've not heard of the issue but
advised those who have to contact
customer support Capcom have decided to
remind gamers why resident evil is
awesome which is obviously then created
the controversy over whether resident
evil is still awesome the publisher said
that the series draws people in Judah
with elaborate settings and world as
well as the realism of the epidemic
disaster story as for the next
installment Capcom has said they're
going to touch on new possibility that
will appeal to players globally that
josh feel a vague aside do you see
resident evil getting its groove back or
not let me know it's now January which
apart from being the month of breaking
resolutions is also the month of you
getting BioShock Infinite and DMC for
free if you're a PlayStation Plus
subscriber Sony had spent December
giving you Borderlands 2 but now you can
grab either of these for free as well as
brothers a tale of two sons if you're so
inclined here's
or users will be able to get themselves
don't starve while those of you with a
Vita can snag worms battle island and
smart as to round that off the holiday
season also saw Nintendo continuing to
remind consumers that the way you is not
a peripheral the publisher of come full
circle after their massive
miscommunication and have launched an
advertisement that straight up tells the
viewer that the Wii U is entirely new
technology and a successor to the way do
you guys think the ad was necessary or
as a message come through loud and clear
at this point you can let me know what
you think in the comments down below or
on my Twitter where I'm access McDonald
this week on site things worth checking
out include Danny's excellent year in
the life of a game of video my
retrospective on 2013 seriously crappy
games and to top it all off see half of
our UK office get drunk and film it in
the name of science in reality check
those are all the things that I have for
you but be sure to leave me all your
favorite stories and unrealistic new
year's resolutions and just McDowell and
I will catch you again next week